Okay. Um, good morning. Today we do um,
Sigmund Freud.
Uh, first what I will do is I will put
Freud
in the context of the Western
religious, intellectual, and literary
tradition.
All right. So, in the beginning, um, the
main religion for us humans during the
um, Ice Age
was animism.
Okay? And the idea of animism is that we
humans are no are no different from
every other living conscious being in
the world.
Uh, we are like the trees, we are like
the animals, we're all interconnected
together.
And life is just a cycle
um, of life and death, birth and
rebirth.
All right? And this is this religion is
still around today in many primitive
societies, for example, in the Amazon.
And then we transition to the mother
goddess.
So,
as we became more agricultural,
fertility was more and more important.
We needed to have more children, and we
needed to grow more crops. And so we
began to worship the mother goddess.
And women were of very high status
at this stage in history.
But as populations grew
and towns came into being,
they came into competition with each
other. They started to war against each
other. This created polytheism.
Polytheism is
the idea that
each place has its own god that's its
patron.
And when these places come into conflict
and war, the way they settle disputes is
the losing party, their god becomes
subservient to
the winning god. And this creates the
idea of the pantheon that we see in
Greek, Roman mythologies, as well as
Norse mythologies.
Now,
the radical break from this tradition
was the birth of monotheism.
Now,
um there's going to be a lot of
scholarly debate
about which was the first monotheistic
religion. Some say
um there are certain
Egyptian cults that were monotheistic.
Some say the Jews were. Some say the
Zoroastrians were.
In this class, um
what you what you learn is actually it
was the Christians
who were the first true monotheistic
religion.
And the reason why is the Christians
introduced
the idea
of the Holy Trinity.
Okay? Remember what the Holy Trinity is.
The Holy Trinity, the idea is
God,
Jesus,
and the Holy Spirit.
These are different
entities,
but they are co-equal to each other.
They are separate,
but unified.
They are different, but equal.
And this idea,
um it's very hard for us to
logically reconcile.
The only way for us to understand this
is if God is both nothing and
everything.
Therefore, it excludes everything. There
can be no other God with our God.
Okay, and this is the idea of
monotheism.
And the power of monotheism is that for
the first time in human history, it
creates the idea of the individual.
Because when God is everything,
you have a direct connection with God.
And it removes you from the community.
Okay? Now,
this will create a lot of problems in
the future.
But at this point in history, remember,
monotheism is being promoted by the
Roman Empire as a way to consolidate its
rule over its vast territory.
At this stage in history, this is not a
problem. The reason why is mediating you
and God is the Catholic Church.
But not only that, the Catholic Church
mediates
God
for everyone.
So, in this way,
the church creates its own community.
Okay? So, at this stage in history, this
is not a problem.
But remember,
um the church becomes corrupt, and there
are many religious form reformers
who
believe that you don't really need the
church
in order to access God. In fact, you
have a moral imperative
to access God directly through the
Bible. You have to read the Bible Bible
by yourself, and you have to interpret
it properly.
Okay? And so, obviously, the most famous
reform is Martin Luther. Now, this is
important because what will happen is
by limiting the church,
you create direct direct access to God,
and this creates
the idea of crisis
in
faith.
The idea of crisis in faith is
how do you truly
know as a person
whether or not
you love God.
And how do you know God loves you?
Think about your mother, right?
You know your mother loves you, and you
know you love your mother, but there are
many days when you really hate your
mother.
And you fight with your mother.
Okay? So,
um it's hard for us not to doubt
ourselves.
And so, this creates the crisis in faith
because
um in Protestantism
you are required to show absolute faith
and devotion in God. If you doubt, if
you hesitate, you will be condemned to
hell.
All right, so this creates the idea of
crisis in faith.
Um historically, there have been many
solutions to this problem. Different um
uh prophets have proposed different
solutions.
So, let's look at three different
solutions. All right, so the first
solution
is the idea of wealth
accumulation.
All right, so these these are the
Calvinists, right? They argue
that to show your true faith in God
and for you to prove to yourself God
truly loves you,
you make a lot of money.
All right, that is a testament to the
power of your faith, wealth
accumulation. So, that's one solution.
It's a very popular solution. It's what
gives us capitalism today.
The second solution
is that of jihad.
You will die for your faith. You'll
sacrifice yourself to promote the truth
of God.
All right, that's also a solution.
Um and then there's one more solution
that we will discuss today.
And it's hard for us to truly
understand, so I'm going to I'm going to
take some time to explain it fully,
okay?
This is the idea of
transgression.
So, um let me explain it to you slowly.
The idea is this.
You must demonstrate complete and
absolute faith in God to be one of the
elect, to go to heaven.
To do so, you must demonstrate courage.
Um you must
um demonstrate fanaticism.
The best way to do that
is to prove yourself to God by rejecting
the laws of man.
By rejecting human morality.
By
um rejecting social taboos. By breaking
social taboos, actually demonstrate your
faith in God.
All right. Now, I know this sounds like
a strange idea,
um but let me give you an example
to show you
what this means.
Let's just say that in school,
I decide to start a new class.
And this new class is called individual
empowerment.
And my very first assignment to all my
students is
I want you guys to go shoplift.
I want you guys to go steal a piece of
candy
from a small store.
And of course, you are disgusted and you
are appalled
by this suggestion.
What if you get caught?
Well, you might get expelled from
school. You might be uh jailed.
Your parents may punish you.
You may be outcast from society.
And then I tell you as And then I tell
you
have faith.
Trust me.
When you do this and you break the
social taboo that's preventing you from
real realizing your full potential, you
will feel an extreme sense of exhil-
exhilaration,
liberation, excitement, and this will
motivate you to do greater things in
life.
By breaking taboos, by transgression
against society, and showing your true
faith in God,
you will
master your destiny.
Okay? And so, you guys go and you go
steal something
from the store. You get away with it,
and guess what?
You feel excited. You feel exhilarated.
You feel energized.
Okay? And that's the idea of
transgression.
And um this has always been a very
uh
um
this and and this has been around for us
for like hundreds of years as well,
okay? So, these are the three main ways
that historically
um the religious practitioners
practitioners practitioners have tried
to resolve the issue of the crisis of
faith, right? Wealth accumulation,
that's Calvinist. Jihad. And but you and
you also have transgression. Remember
transgression? It's very important for
discussion, okay? So, remember this
idea.
Now, um another
way to resolve the crisis of faith is
through philosophy, epistemology.
Epistemology.
Epistemology is really just means
the theory of knowledge.
How do ideas
come together?
Where does knowledge come from? How do
we know what we know, right? Because the
crisis of crisis of faith is essentially
how do we know?
So, epistemology is really
um philosophy's attempt to resolve this
crisis of faith.
Remember before we we Kant.
And
Kant proposed the idea of
active
subjectivity.
Active subjectivity is the idea that we
are not just passive
uh
consumers of information. We actively
participate in reality. We imagine
reality in a way that allows us to
understand it.
Um what Kant tells us is
we imagine space and time onto reality,
which creates a world of appearance for
us to understand.
The problem with Kant is
what is reality?
And Kant doesn't know. In fact, he tells
us it is impossible to truly understand
reality.
And this creates a problem because
if that's the case, then how do we know
if
reality exists or not. It's entirely
possible that we are in a computer
simulation.
Right? So
So Hegel
comes along and resolves this issue by
introducing the idea of the Geist. Okay?
The Geist, the spirit, the mind. He
argues that this is the manifestation of
God that is the underlying basis of all
reality.
And from this reality comes the material
world.
What What What will then happen is that
Marx
will come along and he will argue
that Geist is really history.
Hegel believes that the Geist is in a
process of working working itself with
the world. It's becoming the world and
it's bringing us along with it so that
one day everyone will achieve full
enlightenment.
Marx inverts Hegel and puts the material
world before the world of ideas.
And he argues that history, it is a
movement of class struggle.
And the end of history is when all plus
class struggle ceases and we all become
equal in a workers paradise.
Why? Because as capitalism becomes worse
and worse,
as the proletariat increase in number
but are exploited in greater uh
but but are oppressed
by the capitalist, eventually the
proletariat, you and me, will develop
class consciousness and we will unite
and we'll overthrow the capitalist class
through collective action.
Okay?
So,
this is Marx.
Now, today we will study Freud.
Because what will happen is Freud will
come along and he will present a
completely different conception
of the movement of history
and of the individual.
He argues
that the individual is really just
unconscious forces embedded within the
brain.
Okay? So, these three forces are the
super ego,
the ego,
and the id.
The ego is who we think we are. The
super ego are these social forces that
act upon us. And the id are these hidden
sexual urges.
And what he will argue is actually these
hidden sexual urges
are the true foundations of who we are
as well as of civilization. And he names
two of them, okay? The first is is what
is called the Oedipole
the Oedipole
complex.
The second is Electra complex.
So, remember that
Oedipus is a character from Greek
mythology.
A king who killed his father and married
his mother.
Electra is also a character from
uh Greek mythology.
Um a woman who wanted to kill um her
um mother and marry his father, okay? Uh
Electra is from the Aeschylus play The
Oresteia.
Um Freud was remarkably well read in
Greek mythology as well as world
literature. So, he argues these are the
two
fundamental basis of who we are. If
you're a man, you have the Oedipole
complex. If you have If you're a woman,
you are the you have the Electra
complex.
Okay? Now,
um
this is all strange because
Kant makes sense.
Hegel makes sense.
Marx makes sense. They all seem to
flow from each other. And then you have
Freud.
Okay?
So, the question then is
where did he get this idea?
Where
Where's this from?
How did he develop this idea?
All right? So, so, so, so, we'll look at
this a question in great detail today.
All right. So, at So, um everyone sort
of knew
that Freud's theory of the unconscious
is problematic.
Um and he had a very famous student, his
best student, his heir-apparent, named
Carl Jung.
And Carl Jung really saw Freud
as a father, and he worshipped Freud.
And he wanted to improve on Freud's
theory of the unconscious.
And over time, what Carl Jung will do is
he will systematize this idea.
Okay? So, for Carl Jung,
we have the ego.
And the ego
is
made up of two forces, the conscious
force
and the
subconscious.
The subconscious
is also divided into the personal
as well as the collective.
Sorry, uh it's not subconscious,
unconscious, okay? Unconscious. So, the
personal conscious are just our
our memories, our experiences.
The collective unconscious
is the collection
of
all societies' memories and experiences.
Um and they are captured
and expressed whenever we engage in
society. When when we eat the food, when
we talk to people, when we watch movies,
when we read books. Okay? The collective
unconscious is embedded
throughout society. You breathe it like
you would breathe air.
Okay? So,
um
Carl uh sorry, Jung also says that I
we have the animus
and the anima.
In other words,
we
Sorry. In other words,
we are made up of two opposing forces,
the male and the female.
There's a duality to us.
Um so,
when when we meet people,
the ego projects a persona.
Okay? The persona is just basically our
best self in a certain social context.
So, in So, in school, you're a student,
and you try to be the best student.
At home, you're a daughter.
Um at McDonald's, you're a friend. Okay?
So, so you are different personas in
different social contexts.
Now,
we try to project our best self,
but
we are made up of a lot of
bad memories, bad thoughts. So, the ego
suppresses
uh
the worst aspects of us in a shadow
form, okay? So, the shadow is really the
alter ego of the ego.
And this,
Jung argues, is what is called the self.
All right?
And what he tells us is
life is a
constant process of self-discovery.
If you truly want to master yourself,
you must discover who you are, and that
will take a lifetime of um
self-exploration.
Got it by a psychotherapist.
All right? And this sounds much more
logical, right?
And it's become really the standard
model for modern-day psychology.
Now, you would think that Freud would be
happy that Carl Jung came up with this
new idea on how to improve his theory.
But Freud
um was infuriated
that Jung would question his theory. In
fact, Freud was notorious for being
control freak. He He excommunicated
Jung, and refused to have any anything
to do with him. In fact, everyone in the
community around Freud
um were now disassociating
disassociating themselves from Carl
Jung, and there would be no
reconciliation between the two ever. And
that's why And that's why Carl Jung had
to had to go and develop his this this
theory.
Okay? So,
um and it's strange because all Carl
Jung is trying to do is improve Freud.
So, that leads That gives us a second
question.
What Why was Freud so afraid of
criticism? Why Why was he so secretive?
All right?
And then the third question that we will
look at today here
Why does idea become so popular? In
fact, the ideas of Freud and Carl Jung
will become the basis of a major
cultural movement called modernism.
And modernism is the cultural movement
that we still live in today.
Now, there are many different
definitions of modernism, but for us the
easiest definition is
cult
of the self.
We live in a world, in a society, in a
culture that's obsessed
with
ourselves, with self-improvement, with
self-empowerment.
All right? So,
um
we will look at
where this came from, okay? So, the
three questions we're we're looking at
today is, first of all, where did Freud
get this idea for the Oedipal complex?
Second is,
why was Freud so secretive? And the
third question is, what explains Freud's
popularity? Why was he
Why was he so influential? And why was
his influence able to spread so quickly?
And
what I will show you today
is
uh
Freud became so influential, so famous
not because his psychoanalyst system was
designed to help his patients.
Ultimately, his system was designed to
protect the interests of
powerful interests, powerful men. Okay,
that's my argument to you uh
today.
Okay, so having made the general
argument,
what I want to do now is look at the
evidence to support the argument.
Okay? So, um
again, this is a chart that summarizes
the different perspectives of these four
major thinkers: Kant, Hegel, Marx, and
Freud. Okay? So, to summarize the main
ideas, Freud believes that our sexual
urges is what underpins our identity as
well as civilization. It's because we
cannot control our sexual urges that
gives rise to religion, which helps us
um cope with our guilt. Okay?
Um he also believes that truth lies in
our suppressed memories.
And in his framework, God has abandoned
us. There's really no God in his system.
We are left to fend for ourselves. We're
left to deal with the trauma all being
alone.
All right.
So, um let's put Freud in his historical
context.
So, Freud lived and worked um at the end
of the 19th century, primarily in
Vienna.
And at this time, Europe was going
through
fundamental social, cultural, economic,
political change.
Um we were transitioning from the
premodern era to the modern era.
Before, we lived primarily in
towns and villages, where we dealt with
with each other emotionally.
And
we had a purpose in our community.
But when we moved to the cities,
um it is money and the clock that
regulates our life. And it's still true
today, right?
So, um when you come to school,
um
what controls your behavior?
It's the It's your It's your grades,
as well as the clock, right? If you are
late for class, if you're not If you're
absent, then you are then your grades
get deducted. All right, so it's the
same concept as we have today.
All right.
Um
Now,
because of these social changes,
two new fields, sociology and
psychology, are developed in order to
try to
um understand what these changes mean
for us as humans.
So, in the fields of sociology, there
are three major thinkers, pioneers of
this time, Max Weber,
Emile Durkheim, and this man, Georg
Simmel. And Georg Simmel wrote a
wonderful essay
called The Metropolis and Mental Life,
in which he describes
what the impact of moving to the city
has on people, okay? So, we'll just read
a couple sentences.
Instead of reacting emotionally, the
metropolitan type reacts primarily in a
rational manner, thus creating a mental
predominance through the intensification
of consciousness, which in turn is
caused by it. Thus, the reaction of the
met- metropolitan person to those events
is moved to a sphere of mental activity,
which is least sensitive and which is
furthest removed from the depths of the
personality. Okay, so let's use a
metaphor.
Let's take up food.
When you're in the village, you grow
your own food, and then you
make the food, you eat it, and that's
it, okay? You know exactly where the
food comes from, you know how it's made,
and you're not really curious about the
food.
But the one one of the thing about the
city is you get
um exposed to all different types of
cuisine, all different types of flavors,
and that excites your imagination.
You're much more curious about it.
Right? You're You want to know where
this food is is made.
The problem though, of course, is this
is all an abstraction. You have
absolutely no idea where the food comes
from. You have absolutely no idea how
where the food is made. And quite
honestly, you don't even know whether
the food is healthy for you or not.
Okay? So So
um
the city life is a higher abstraction.
And of course, today with the internet,
which is even a higher abstraction,
okay? So you go from a village to the
city, now to the internet.
Um
of course,
this creates a lot of problems for
people. Because the this transition
causes psychological issues. And a few
major psychological issues are
enemy, okay? Um and what this means is
before the village, you know exactly
what to do.
Um but you you move to a city, there are
different rules, and that confuses you.
For example, in the village, if someone
punches you, you punch back. And then
afterwards, you become friends.
In the city, if someone punches you and
you punch back, you both go to jail.
So it's confusing for people, okay?
Uh alienation means
that you have absolutely no freedom in
the city. You work from 9:00 to 5:00.
You get up at You get up at 6:00 in the
morning, get on the subway at 7:00, then
get to work at 9:00.
Then you get off of work at 5:00 and get
home at 10:00, okay? So everything is
the same reg- same regulated life. It's
And it's um and you lack freedom, okay?
That that causes alienation. The last
idea is disenchantment, where you feel
as though you are just a machine and you
have lost human agency.
Okay? So this creates lots of
psychological issues. And that's why at
this time, psychol- psychologists become
much more popular.
Um
This is Sigmund Freud.
And um he was a very ambitious
uh medical student who became a
psychologist.
And he started to see patients.
And these patients were often young
women who were hysterical. His history
His Historical is not a word we use
anymore, but back then it just meant
that they couldn't control their
emotions.
Um, they were prone to outbursts,
crying.
When they saw a man, when they were
touched by a man, they screamed, they
cried. They couldn't form healthy
relationships.
Okay?
So, Freud was tasked with figuring out
why this is happening and trying to help
these women.
And he spent a lot of time with these
women.
And he did something pretty novel at the
time, which is he basically he just won
their trust and asked them directly,
"Why are you like this?" And the woman,
um, after many sessions,
after becoming friends with Freud, they
started to confide in Freud. And they
told him the truth, which is, "I'm
hysterical. I'm afraid of men touching
me because when I was young,
my father abused me."
And Freud, at first, was shocked.
I think everyone would be shocked.
But, over time,
he would hear this story from so many
different patients with the same
symptoms that he concluded that they
must be telling him the truth. And he
wrote a very famous paper in 1896 called
The Etiology of Hysteria. Etiology just
means origins, okay? And in it he says,
"My previously communicated assumption
that trauma, specifically sexual trauma,
cannot be stressed enough as a
pathologic agent, was confirmed anew.
Even children of respected, high-minded,
puritanical families fall victim to real
rape
much more frequently than one had dared
to suspect.
Either parents themselves seek
substitution for their lack of
satisfaction in this pathological manner
or else trusted persons such as
relatives
um
abuse the endurance
and innocence of
children. Okay? So, he's arguing that
abuse is much more common than we are
led to believe. Even those that we think
are pillars of society engage in this
sort of abuse. So, what he's doing is
that he's becoming an advocate for
advocate for this woman.
He's telling the world, "They're not
crazy. They're not being hysterical.
They were traumatized and that's why
they're behaving like this. If you got
hit by a car
uh your leg wouldn't um you wouldn't be
able to walk. Well, these women are the
same way.
They were traumatized physically when
they were young and that's why they're
behaving like this. That's why they have
problems forming these emotional bonds
with others."
Um
The symptoms of hysteria are determined
by certain experiences of the patients
which have operated in a traumatic
fashion and which are being reproduced
in a psychological life in the form of
pneumatic symbols, okay? So, what he's
saying is this is not made up in the
mind. This happened physically and then
it gets represented in the mind.
Um
So, that's Freud arguing for um
his patients.
Now, let me introduce you to a man named
Jeffrey Masson.
And he wrote a book called The Assault
on Truth.
His story is this. He went to Harvard
and he became very interested in
psychoanalysis.
And he studied began to study it and he
became friends with Anna Freud who is
Sigmund Freud's daughter.
Anna Freud um thought very highly of
him.
And
um
she trusted him with the letters of
Sigmund Freud. And before this was this
was
not open to the public, and no one knew
about these letters.
But, Jeffrey Masson spent years going
over the letters.
And what he discovered shocked him.
The early Freud and the later Freud are
two different people.
They have two different theories about
trauma and abuse. Okay? And in his book,
he presents the evidence, which are
Freud's letters
to friends.
All right? So, let's just read a couple.
This is early Freud. I therefore put
forward thesis that at the bottom of
every case of hysteria, there are one or
more occurrences of premature
experience, occurrences which belong to
the earliest years of childhood.
Okay?
There are a whole number of other things
that vouch for reality of infantile
sexual scenes. In the first place,
there's a uniformity which exhibit in
certain details.
So, what he's saying is
um I know that people don't believe me,
but
the evidence is clear. I've talked to
different people. They don't know each
other. They're telling me the same
story. They're providing the same
details.
So, either there's this giant
conspiracy,
or they're telling the truth.
It is less easy to refute the idea that
the doctor forces reminiscences of this
sort on the patient, that he influences
him by suggesting to imagine and
reproduce them.
Nevertheless, it appears to me equally
untenable. I've never yet succeeded in
forcing on a patient a scene I was
expecting to find in such a way that he
seemed to be living through it with all
the appropriate feelings.
Perhaps others may be more successful in
this.
When you read Freud, you see him as a
very clear,
as very nuanced, as a very balanced
thinker. Okay? He accepts there are
different possibilities. It's possible
that
he himself is suggesting false memories
to his patients.
And he and he
and and he says, "This This is possible,
but I have failed to achieve this goal.
And there are others who may be better
at this than I,
but I haven't been able to do it, okay?
So, based on this evidence,
um
he argues that
these patients must be telling the
truth. And this is the early Freud.
Um this is Sándor Ferenczi, and for the
longest time, they were colleagues. They
were best friends.
They were both advocates for patients.
And then, um
they had a falling out.
Okay? They started to
um they they they basically refused to
talk to each other anymore, okay?
And the reason why is Sándor Ferenczi
continued to advocate for
um patient rights,
whereas
Sigmund Freud completely changed his
attitude. All right? So, let's look at
the new Freud.
Since child masturbation is such a
general occurrence, and is at the same
time so poorly remembered, it must have
an equivalent in psychic life. And in
fact, it is found in the fantasy
encountered in most female patients,
namely that the father seduced her in
childhood. This is a later reworking,
which is designed to cover up the
recollection of infantile sexual
activity, and represents an excuse and
extenuation thereof.
The grain of truth contained in this
fantasy lies in the fact that the
father, by way of his innocent caresses
in earliest childhood, has actually
awakened the little girl's sexuality. It
is these seemingly affectionate fathers
that are the ones who then endeavor to
break the child of the habit of
masturbation.
Okay. So, what
Freud is trying to say is
young girls, from very early age, they
are sexual animals. They have these
urges.
And they have these longings for the
father.
And it's compounded by the fact that the
father in his innocence
hugs and caresses his little girl.
It's made worse when the father notices
that the girl is masturbating and tries
to stop her.
And this creates a sense of both
resentment,
hatred, and more longing.
Okay? So, now what Freud is saying is
it's not the father. The father did
nothing. He's innocent.
The
girl is the one who who who because of
these sexual urges has all these sexual
fantasies
that
she is no longer able to differentiate
between fantasy and reality.
All right?
So, um
this is from from the essay Fragments of
an Analysis of Hysteria. The love-hungry
little girl, unhappy at having to share
her parents' affection with her brothers
and sisters, realizes that all that
tenderness comes flowing back when her
parents are made anxious by her illness.
The little The girl now knows a way of
calling forth her parents' love. So, now
he's explaining why hysteria is so
common in society. And the answer is
very simple.
Women are desperate for attention. It's
that simple.
They're fine. They have no issues. They
just want attention.
And that's why they
are hysterical, okay? Because they know
that illness attracts attention from
caregiving
uh males.
Um this is this is Sigmund Freud's book
Civilization and Its Discontents. And in
it he
expresses his contempt for women in
society. All right, let's read it.
Furthermore, women should soon come into
opposition to civilization and display
the retarding and restraining influence.
Those very women who in the beginning
laid the foundations of civilization by
claims of their love.
Women represent the interests of the
family and of sexual life. The work of
civilization has become increasingly the
business of men. It confronts them them
with ever more difficult task and
compels them to carry out instinctual
sublimations of which women are little
capable.
All right, so Freud's saying this.
We must thank women because without
women there would be no civilization.
They give birth. They raise families.
But men are smarter than women.
And so men are tasked with the
responsibility of building civilization,
of creating science, of creating
literature, of creating philosophy, of
politics,
of administration.
Okay? And
but what all women want is attention, to
be doted on. And that's why women hate
civilization. First of all, because
they're not smart and they can't really
uh contribute to civilization, but also
because it takes
uh men away from from them.
Okay?
So, now the question then is
okay, this is like really strange
because
the Freud that we encountered earlier
was a
scientist.
Um very clear, very nuanced,
very subtle in his thinking.
This Freud,
he's like a
myth maker. He's almost like a priest.
Okay? So, so what explains this
trans- transition?
Okay, well, there's there's a very
simple explanation, right? Um the simple
explanation, which is simple
explanation, is
um
he may be treating his patients who are
young women,
but who's paying the bills?
The father, right? It's the father who's
paying
Freud. So,
um
if Freud went to the father and said,
"Oh, I talked to your daughter. It's
your fault that she's like this." Well,
they wouldn't be very happy.
Okay? So,
um we can understand why, at the end of
the day, Freud decided that he needed to
change his story if he wanted to
maintain his clientele.
Um
So, the question then is, okay,
is there evidence to suggest
that
sexual trauma and abuse was common in
Vienna at this time in history, the late
19th century? And the answer is yes.
There is some piece of evidence, okay?
Not complete, okay? But there's some
piece of evidence to suggest this was
actually a thing in Vienna in the late
19th century. So, um
this is So, Vienna is part of the
Austria-Hungary Empire, and there are
lots of secret societies and religious
cults at this time.
Okay? One of them is called Frankism.
And Frankism
uh
um
rejected Jewish norms
and he and
believed
they were obligated to transgress more
boundaries. Okay, remember the question
of faith, right? How do you demonstrate
um your faith in God? How do you know
God loves you? How do you know you're
faithful? Well, you break taboos.
And they were breaking a lot of taboos.
The Frankists engaged in sexually
promiscuous rites, such as the infamous
1756 incident where they were allegedly
caught dancing around a half-naked
woman.
Um at its height, Frankism claimed
perhaps 50,000 followers. That's a lot.
50,000 followers is a lot. And a lot of
them were powerful people.
Um primarily Jews living in the
Polish-Lithuanian Commonwealth, as well
as Central and Eastern Europe.
Later, Frankists were encouraged to
convert en en masse to Catholicism,
okay?
And
um
so, who are these people?
Well, they are followers of a man named
Sabbatai Zevi, who lived in 19th century
who was a um
Jewish rabbi who lived in 19th century
Ottoman Empire.
And for many, he was extremely
charismatic and he was basically their
Messiah. Okay, he was the Jewish
Messiah. And he preached a religion of
transgression because transgression
meant courage. It meant empowerment. Um
it meant true faith. And he had a lot of
followers. And that's why the Sultan
called him and then said, "Okay, I'll
give you a choice. You can either
continue doing what you do and I'll kill
you or you convert to Islam."
So, he converted to Islam.
But when he did so, he told his
followers,
"I did so because God doesn't care
about what you do. God cares about
what's in your heart. As long as you're
true to God, what you do in life does
not matter."
Okay? And the religion he started is
still around
uh today. Okay?
And
um
this is from Wikipedia, okay? All this
is from Wik- Wikipedia and you can look
look you can look at it online to make
sure that I'm not making making this up.
All right? So, as part of
this movement,
um
I mean, you can read this, right?
All right? Um sexual abuse was actually
pretty common.
So, we have evidence to suggest that
yes,
um
these women were probably telling the
truth. And for a new new soul, but Freud
ultimately had to change his story in
order to protect protect his livelihood.
Okay, but there's also another reason
why Freud had to change his story. Okay?
And this it has to do with with a man
named Ignaz Semmelweis.
Ignaz Semmelweis lived in 1840s
uh Vienna. He was and he he he was a
doctor who worked at
uh Vienna General Hospital.
And he was in charge of two maternity
clinics, places where women give birth.
Um same hospital, same staff, but the
maternity but the maternity rate at the
second clinic was much higher than the
first clinic. Women would
uh could could die giving birth because
of fever. So, 10% of women were dying in
the second clinic.
And only about 3% were dying in the
first clinic.
So,
Ignaz Semmelweis, he was appalled
by by this.
And so, he launched an investigation as
to what was happening. And he spent 7
months, a long, long time, trying to
figure out what happened what was
happening.
And he looked at all the different
possibilities, including weather,
including um treatment, including
personnel, everything, okay?
And then he had a radical breakthrough.
He had an insight, which is this.
In the second clinic, it was a teaching
hospital.
So, doctors when in the morning would
work with cadavers, okay? They would
show students how to how to dissect
dissect cadavers. And then in the
afternoon, they'd go and deliver babies.
And
Semmelweis,
he didn't know why because at this time
germs were not a thing. People didn't
know about know about the existence of
germs.
Um, he didn't know why, but he he
theorized that there could be a
connection. So, he created a protocol.
He basically had everyone wash their
hands
uh using a um a formula of um water,
chlorine, and lime. And we still use it
today, exactly the same formula today.
And so, he tried this protocol, and it
was a miracle. Because because after
people started to wash their hands,
no one died in childbirth anymore.
And Semmelweis, being a rigorous
scientist, he collected all this data,
conducted a lot of experiments to prove
this had to be true that washing your
hands could save lives. And then he
presented his findings to the staff, the
doctors of Vienna General Hospital,
believing that they would um they would
praise him and then promote this all
throughout Europe in order to save as
many lives as possible.
Instead, the doctors told him
they had to um
they had to keep this quiet. Um they'll
promote Semmelweis.
Uh they respect him and he did amazing
work, but if word came out that uh this
was true, then people would know that
they were responsible for the deaths of
these women before and their reputation
would be in tatters.
Um and then Semmelweis, of course,
responded by, "Yes, I understand that,
but we don't publish our findings. If we
don't let the world know know about
this, more women are going to die in
childbirth."
And they fought for a long time, years
and years, and eventually Semmelweis, he
was
black uh blacklisted. He would He would
not He was not allowed to work work ever
in hospital again. And then ultimately
he was confined to an insane asylum
where he was killed by the guards.
And he let And he died
leaving a young family.
And so that's what happens to you when
you defy powerful people
in Vienna uh in the 19th century. And
Freud didn't want the same fate. Okay?
And he al- he also had a young family.
Um so this story is is horrible, but if
if you don't believe me, you can go on
W- Wikipedia, okay?
Um he was institutionalized in an insane
asylum
um by his colleagues. In the asylum, he
was beaten by the guards. He died 14
days
later.
All right? So,
this is the fate that will happen to you
in Vienna if you defy powerful people.
So So now we have an explanation for why
Freud made the transition.
Why he changed his story.
But now there's another problem, which
is
how does Freud convince his patients go
along?
Right?
Before he told his patients, "I believe
you." Uh
um and they trusted him. And now he's
changing his story.
So, how can he convince them
that they in fact do suffer from
sexual fantasies?
And like this this experience of sex
sexual abuse is all just made up in the
head. And that's a very hard job to do.
So, the solution is
the interpretation of dreams.
All right? So, Freud pioneered a new way
of hypnotizing
um
his patients.
So, together they would analyze their
dreams. All right? Because if you if you
talk about their memories and their
past, they're going to fight back and
say, "I remember clearly." If you talk
about their dreams, that allows you to
um suggest subtly
new ideas and new memories. To basically
implant
uh new memories in
basically gaslight that person. Okay?
Does that make sense?
All right? So, the interpretation of
dreams.
So, um
that is the story of Freud.
Okay?
But, this leaves a question is
why did it spread throughout the world?
All right? And that's something that we
will look at in part three.
So, a lot of the influence of Freud has
to do with Carl Jung who will take his
ideas of the unconscious and systematize
it for popular um consumption. Okay?
Um so, we already discussed his
framework where we are all dualities.
Okay? We have an ego, but we also have a
shadow. We have a conscious, but also a
unconscious. A personal as well as
collective. An animus and an anima.
Um Jung popularized ideas of personality
types. All right? Introvert, um
extrovert, which is what we still use
today.
All right. Um
the main influence is in modernism.
A transformative art movement beginning
around the um early 20th century. All
right, so
arguably the first great
modern
artist is James Joyce, who in 1922
published Ulysses.
Um,
James Joyce was Irish. He was an Irish
expatriate. And he actually studied
Dante in university. So, um he wrote
Ulysses
um
as a way to imitate almost surpass
Dante.
And of course Ulysses refers to Homer's
Odyssey.
Now, um
we're going to read a passage from
Ulysses to understand
um the power of his writing. Okay?
Inedible modality of the visible. At
least that if no more
part through my eyes. Signatures of all
things I'm here to read. Sea spawn and
sea rack, the nearing tide that rusty
boot. Stark green, blue silver rust,
colored signs, limits of the dinfund,
pleiades in bodies. Okay. Um what does
this mean? I have no idea.
All right, I I have no idea. Um I can
explain to you Dante, I can explain to
you Homer and Shakespeare, but I
struggle with James Joyce.
And there are two reasons why. Okay, the
first reason is
he was um a singer.
So, you have to read what he writes as
though it's music. Okay, it's meant to
be read read aloud. So, it's musical.
And that's really the power of his
writing. He's more focusing on the style
rather than the substance.
Okay, that's the first thing. Second
thing is that he was extremely well
read.
And everything that he writes in every
sentence, there are multiple allusions
and references to other books, okay? So,
you must have read what he read. You
must have experienced what he
experienced in order to understand him.
And there are those who argue that
Ulysses is the greatest book in the
world. In fact, if you go online, you
just Google the best book ever written
in human history, James Joyce is up
there, okay?
Uh Ulysses is either number one or
number two on this list of 50 best books
in human history.
Um
Um and there is there are many who tell
me
yeah, James Joyce is hard, but if you
spend the time to
go over what he's writing and connect
the references, you will have a
transformative intellectual experience.
Okay? It's almost like doing a jigsaw
puzzle.
Um and that's all true, okay? But think
about what they're saying. They're
saying what what they're really saying
is that
James Joyce believes that he is God.
He has the mind of God.
And if you spend the time to understand
what he writes, and it might take you
years, decades, okay? You will access
the mind of God.
That's very different from Dante,
which is trying to use poetry to bring
people
into
the mind of God, which is the truth of
the world, okay? Dante's is a lot more
accessible than James Joyce. So, look
let's look at the differences.
Um modern literature, as represented by
Ulysses, it is elitist. It's
self-referential
Okay? It just has a lot of allusions and
references, but you don't you don't
actually don't know what the meaning is.
Like, what is the bigger story here?
And it's used to something called stream
of consciousness writing, which is it's
trying to capture the mind as it thinks
and works, okay?
That's different from other from Homer,
who is who is very democratic. He was
trying to bring beauty and truth to the
people
through epic poetry, okay?
So, starting with modern literature, we
have this abrupt change in the nature of
literature.
Before, it was about empowering people
to seek the truth for themselves.
Now, modern literature, it's really just
this very elite club of very arrogant,
haughty people, okay?
Um
James Joyce was good friends with
Virginia Woolf. In fact, Virginia Woolf
actually published um
James Joyce. In 1927,
Woolf published a book called To the
Lighthouse, and it's probably her most
famous work.
And um in it, she's also trying to
respond to Joyce.
To the Lighthouse, it's very much based
on Homer's Odyssey.
And
um
it's it's a very it's extremely well
written, okay? Let's
Let's just look at what she writes.
There were the eternal problems,
suffering, death, the poor. There was
always a woman dying of cancer even
here. And yet she had said to all these
children, you shall go through with it.
To eight people she had sent word that
at least to that, and the bill for the
greenhouse would be 50 pounds. Okay, so
what she's what she's doing is she's
reading a book and she's thinking about
the issues raised by book, but she's
also thinking about life. Like, oh, I I
have to I have to go and do something,
okay? And that's really how our minds
work. So, this captures really well
stream of consciousness thinking.
And she's heavily influenced by Freud,
right? She's trying to go into the
unconscious and trying to figure out how
the conscious unconscious works. To the
Lighthouse is really about memory, about
perception, about remembering.
All right? Um
but again, it's extremely
self-indulgent.
And it's inward-looking. And it's very
And again, it's a radical departure from
traditional literature. So, let's
compare
um modern literature with Dostoevsky.
Remember, before we discuss Dostoyevsky
For Dostoyevsky, the heart is a deep
impenetrable ocean.
And our psychology responds to external
events. We live in the world and respond
to the world.
We must surrender ourselves to others to
seek salvation and redemption. We cannot
rely on ourselves to forgive ourselves,
to love ourselves. We must rely on
others. We are We are in a community of
people, okay? So, these are the truths
of Dostoyevsky. But, when we get to
modern literature
Self-discovery will allow for
self-mastery. Our psychology responds to
our suppressed memories. We can be our
own salvation and redemption. It's too
optimistic.
Uh it's too positive.
Okay? It's saying that, "Hey, if you're
poor
um don't worry about it.
As long as you think happy thoughts,
you'll be good." Okay? This this idea of
positive psychology, right? That we have
today.
Um
Carl Jung and Friedrich Nietzsche also
had a major influence on
Pablo Picasso.
And you can see it from his painting um
Head of a Woman, okay? Now, what you
will notice is it's it's it's it's a
Cubist portrait of a woman, but if you
look further, it's actually two people
as well, okay?
And so, what this is doing is it's
visually representing
the theory of the self as presented by
Jung. Okay? So, so do do you see the
similarities? Great.
Okay.
So, why is this art spreading throughout
the world?
Well, I mean, not to be conspiracy
theorists, but let's look at an article.
All right? Was modern art really a CIA
psyop?
All right? So, this article is from
Jstor, which is a academic journal, very
mainstream. And this let's read what it
writes. In the mid-20th century, modern
art and design represented the
liberalism, individualism, dynamic
activity, and creative risk risk
possible in a free society.
Okay? So, in other words, right now
uh the capitalist West is at war with
communism.
1920s, 1930s, 1940s, communism is
spreading all around the world.
It's very popular among people. It calls
for collective action.
So,
um the capitalist West, the powers that
be, they're spreading Freud.
They're spreading Joyce, they're
spreading Woolf, they're spreading
Picasso, they're spreading all this art,
this modernist art, in order to create a
cult of self.
Because if you believe in the cult of of
the self, if you believe that you are
the source of everything,
then you don't you're not capable of
collective action. Okay? So, in many
ways, this this is a response to the
problem posed by communism. And this
will be um obviously uh most obvious
during the Cold War. Okay? Does that
make sense?
All right.
So, why would that be bad? Why would why
would the cult of self be bad?
Well, this is Mikhail Bakunin, and he
explains it very well in his writings,
okay? So, let's read really quickly what
he wrote.
Having human in man and freedom above
all is a product of a social collective
labor. To be free in absolute isolation
is absurdity invented by theologians,
metaphysicians, who have replaced the
society of humans by that of God, their
phantom. To say that each person feels
free in the presence of God, that is,
the presence of absolute emptiness,
nothingness.
Freedom in isolation, then, is the
freedom of nothingness, or indeed the
nothingness of freedom, slavery. God,
the figment of God, has been
historically the moral source, or
rather, the moral source of all
slaveries.
So, what he's saying is
the radical turning point in human
history is the image of Christianity
because it allows it gives us the idea
of individualism.
And we think that's a good thing because
we were we're taught that individuality
individual individualism means free
choice. It means freedom. What he's
saying is that's that's an absurdity.
We only have freedom from our community.
We only have freedom if others are free
around us.
If we are free but no one else is free
then we are slaves as well.
So because
individuality prevents us from
working with others
from loving others
then that makes us slaves to ourselves.
And that allows for
the powers that be in society to better
control us. Okay? And so what he's
saying is Christianity is a slave
religion.
All right, it was designed to make us
all into slaves.
And this will
And he And Buchanan lived in 19th
century
but if he
read Freud
then he would also argue that
the cult of psychoanalysis it's really
about entrapping yourself in your own
emotions.
As for us, we want neither phantoms nor
nothingness but living human reality and
we recognize that man can feel free, be
free and therefore can achieve freedom.
In order to be free I need to see myself
surrounded by men by free men and be
recognized as such by them. I am free
only when my individuality reflected in
the mirror of the equally free
consciousness of every individual around
me comes back to me strengthened by
everyone's recognition. Okay? So what
he's saying is this, if you want to be
happy
if you want to be free
care about others.
Be kind to others. Work with other
people.
Sacrifice your own self-interest for the
self-interest for for the for the
greater good. Okay? That is what That
what That is That is what will make you
really happy.
And that's generally true because think
about this, okay? If you're by yourself,
will you be happy? Probably not. But if
you have a family, you have kids, you
don't have any freedom,
but you're a happier person. And many in
many in many ways, you're a more free
person because you have better control
of your emotions.
You have more purpose in life.
All right. So,
um
let's bring this to the present day,
social media.
What social media is, it is the
democratization of the cult of the self.
Before, only the wealthy could enjoy the
cult of the self, right? Only the
wealthy could take the time to
self-indulge.
But now with social media, everyone can
participate in the cult of the self. And
that has led to
a global
um epidemic of depression, okay? So,
look look look at your 2015. You see
this huge spike
in depressive symptoms.
Because 2015 is the year when we had
access to smartphones, right? So, now
young people feel they can't do anything
right.
Life is not useful, and I do not enjoy
life. Okay? This huge spike, which has
led to a huge spike in suicide. All
right?
And this is happening throughout the
world, not only in North America and
Europe, but also in Latin America and
East Asia as well. So, the cult of the
self, which originated in Europe, has
now conquered the world through
technology.
All right?
So,
um
that's it.
All right? So, the answer to the three
questions.
The first question is,
where did Freud get his idea?
Second question,
uh why did Freud break up with Jung?
A third question.
Why is Freud's ideas so popular today?
Okay? Well, it's all to serve the
interests of the powerful.
And that's the world we live in today.
The only solution moving forward is if
we rediscover our humanity. We if we are
able to find the courage to
um care about others and put the
interest of others before our own
interest.
We ourselves must choose to kill the
cult of the self.
Okay?
All right. So, uh next class we will do
um
nationalism, right?